et on commence ce journal par un mot de
politique le président du sénat gérard
larcher était ton visite à voisins le
bretonneux vendredi après midi il a
rencontré à cette occasion la maire de
la commune alexandra rosetti l'homme
politique a notamment évoqué avec elle
le projet d'enfouissement de la ligne 18
dans le cadre de la future gare de saint
quentin en yvelines
il a apporté à cette occasion son
soutien à la mer pour que le tracé ne
passe pas sous les habitations du
quartier de la bretonnière on l'écouté
tout à l'heure nous étions devant ce qui
sera le site de la future gare ceci doit
répondre aux préoccupations notamment
des habitants et en même temps leur
apporter ce qui est une chauffe aussi
formidable un transport collectif
car s'il peut y avoir des difficultés
des interrogations nous savons bien tout
ce que notre grand déficit c'est le
transport collectif